you
hi everyone it's Jerry I just got done
doing about 20 puzzles from chess calms
tactics trainer and I'm gonna share 5 of
them with you and in each of these five
it's going to be white to move and if
you'd like to pause the video see if you
can find the best continuation in this
first puzzle for white ok the solution
to this first one is Bishop b7 check
Queen takes Bishop Queen EA check King
in 87 and now Bishop to d4 so a very
forcing line in this first puzzle not a
good solution for black at this point
blocking the Queen you take it and then
take the knight and going here runs into
me so I guess a couple things to bear in
mind we have what's being made use of
right here is I guess we could say
deflection and also forcing black and
black into a position where the Queen
kind of gets in the way of a square the
King may very well want to make use of
it's also maybe even you could regard it
as clearing the way some type of a
clearance move this Bishop b7 move
clearing the way for the Queen to give
ensuing checks in this case Queen the e8
with the follow-up Queen a4 idea alright
let's try this second puzzle here okay
once again it's white to move go ahead
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation for white ok the
solution of this one is e 5 trying to
remove the defender of h7 pawn takes
pawn and now not pawn takes pawn I
believe many of you who are trying to do
this right now went with pawn takes pawn
there's something seriously wrong with
that it's important to recognize that
Black has this tactical motif Queen
takes f2 if King D one rook here and
it's white who's in trouble and if King
takes Queen this allows Knight g4 and
the White Queen is one it's important
from this initial position to realize
that white
in fact down a minor piece so pond takes
going like this is just not going to
work out the better move are the best
the follow-up continuation is not pawn
takes pawn but rather Knight e4 similar
idea trying to remove the knight but
also having a close eye on this again
tactical military takes f29 g4 idea and
black at this point is basically dead
not a not a good play here Knight takes
again that's main Queen takes pawn you
remove this Knight and again we're gonna
have some trouble here I think best is
like this but black is dead all right
let's try puzzle three okay once again
it's white to move go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
of this one is all forcing and it's a
checkmate in eight Queen takes pawn all
these moves are limiting the black King
to either one or two choices rook check
King g8 Knight check this is the only
case here where the King has two options
but it doesn't matter Knight f7 check
came back to g8 rook h8 rook aged seven
rook g7 and rook to h1 eight moves but
again they were all forcing and it's
strictly calculation and looking first
and foremost at the forcing moves that
will hopefully have led to you getting
this problem right here okay let's have
a look at puzzle for once again white to
move positive video see if you can find
the best continuation for white alright
the solution here is to run both sides
in fact run and the trick is to know how
exactly to promote promoting to a queen
is not good it's important to realize
the defensive resource that black has in
the form of stalemate Queen takes Queen
in this case would turn out to be just
that would be stalemate so what do you
do to change that you promote instead to
a rook
if black is promoting now will you just
take it and the King has a legal move
and if instead of promoting at this
point after white promotes to a rook
King a2 is met with King a4 and now if
black promotes well white is simply
going to now be faster to track down
this black pawn over here and will of
course be winning according this might
this pond to a queen soon enough all
right let's have a look at this 5th and
final puzzle once again white to move
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation for white alright the
solution of this last one is rook e8
just looking at forcing those king takes
rook and now now rook a1 the trick here
is in fact to make use of well
eventually the h7 Square Queen a2 King
here
it's an only move and now Queen h7 it's
a very sneaky move which is setting up
what exactly a double check Bishop
Knight hitting the King and well the
King only has two choices but regardless
of which one he chooses row k1 is now
going to be made so that one in fact
turned out to be a mate and five and in
many of these puzzles that we just saw
here they turned out to be all forcing
moves and I hope you got something out
of it feel free to share how you did in
each of these puzzles and I'll catch you
in the next video take care bye white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best play
the solution to this one is really a
nice shot